well protesters in Pittsburgh are
demanding justice after the acquittal of
a white police officer in the shooting
death of an unarmed black teenager 17
year old Antoine Rose jr. was shot three
times as he ran away during a traffic
stop last summer demonstrators marched
in the streets over the weekend to
protest the verdict some believe that
race was a factor in the shooting and an
analysis of nearly 100 million traffic
stops across the country found that
black drivers are stopped more often
than white drivers they're also about
twice as likely to be searched by police
Jennifer Eberhardt is one of the world's
leading experts on unconscious racial
bias she has conducted training sessions
with law enforcement for nearly 15 years
now on how bias influences their
behavior her new book is called bias
uncovering the hidden prejudice that
shapes what we see think and do in it
she explains how all of us are
vulnerable to racial bias Jennifer
Eberhardt joins us at the table to
discuss Jennifer you said we all have it
we all do it and we're afraid to admit
it because we don't want people to think
we are racists yes yes that's right I
think typically when people think about
bias they're thinking about burning
crosses and people filled with hate but
you don't have to be a bigot
to have bias bias is affecting all of us
you don't have to be a bad person and in
fact no bias is not so much a stable
trait but it's something that can be
triggered by the situations we find
ourselves in and some situations make us
more vulnerable to bias and acting on
that bias than others you tell a great
story about your young son who is a
little boy who is a little boy of color
yes but even he had racial bias at a
young age on a plane right that's that's
true he was five years old and we were
on the plane together and he's looking
around he's all wide-eyed you know he's
excited about being on the plane with
mommy and then he sees this guy and he
says hey that guy looks like daddy yeah
and I look at the guy and he doesn't
look anything at all like daddy I mean
like nothing what he says next wasn't so
surprised
well yeah well yeah it turns out he was
the only black guy on the plane and so I
thought I was going to have a
conversation with him about how
all black people look alike because he
was worried that the black guy exactly
was gonna rob the place he was worried
the black guy was going to rob the plane
right and and so I just you know I
looked at him and I said well why would
you think that and he said to me I don't
know why I was thinking that I don't
know why I said that do you realize you
have work to do yeah oh definitely your
own house yeah so Jennifer gives some
give people some other examples of how
implicit bias creeps into their lives as
you say even if people think well I'm
not racist I'm guessing it right I mean
it can creep in to our biases in our own
neighborhoods and how we view people who
were seen as outsiders in that
neighborhood just based on their race
may be people are thinking that okay
this person is suspicious right so so
that's an example or in our workplace
bias can creep in and how we evaluate
others and how we give promotions and
how we hire bias can creep in and the
educational context with teachers and
evaluating students and deciding on who
needs to be disciplined and how severely
you gave an example of race playing a
role in muggings among Asian women in
particular and when they were trying to
identify who the muggers were they they
couldn't decipher between multiple
african-american men that's right and so
this was actually used in in their favor
yeah I mean it was I mean it's almost as
though the muggers actually had access
to the science right and so when the
police officers would catch them and ask
well why did you go there why did she go
to Chinatown and why did you choose
these women to rob they said that they
go there because the Asian people can't
to tell the brothers apart right that
you know they wouldn't be recognized
they couldn't be picked out but you
think that's true in all groups that
whites recognize whites Asians recognize
Asians that depends on the group that
you're formed that you're from that's
what you recognize that's to that that
we don't all look alike to each other we
don't we don't and actually babies as
young as three months of age already are
showing the preference for faces of
their own race so this starts early I
mean it has to do with who we're
surrounded by and our brains get
conditioned to looking at those
faces and being able to distinguish
among them Jennifer how do you unwire
them what you're describing sounds so
hardwired you have them the infant's
tape but the wiring comes from
experience that's the whole thing right
so if you have a social experience where
we're living with each other and we're
not living in segregated spaces say and
you're exposed to faces of other races
all the time then your brain gets tuned
up to that so it's flexible even though
you know it's something that is you know
it's it's wired in but it's a flexible
wiring so how do you bring this science
as you have to police departments across
the country as we continue to see this
wave of white police officer shooting
many times unarmed black men right so
I've worked with a number of different
police departments I haven't worked with
them around use of force but what I've
done is gone in as a subject matter
expert to analyze data on stops and
searches and so so that's where my focus
has been and I'm in Oakland California
right now working with the department
they're on their reform efforts and
trying to figure out a way to decrease
the number of stops of african-americans
in particular who are who ultimately are
not committing the crime and and we've
been figuring out together how to do
that you point out that 99% of the
police stops do not result in deadly
force right which I thought was a very
important point to make right that's
true let me most of us come into contact
with the police during routine traffic
stops and so a lot of my research
focuses on that you know she said one in
three people have been stopped by police
while driving anybody at the table we
should say that bias is on sale tomorrow